[Música]
escala en París Aída Palau
Bienvenidos a todos a este espacio de
radio Francia internacional y de Franz
24 Hoy les Hablamos de una de las bandas
más exitosas y con más trayectoria de
México más de medio siglo en activo
millones y millones de discos vendidos
siete premios Grammy y 12 Grammy latinos
reinventaron el corrido con decenas de
temas sobre los migrantes Les estamos
hablando de Los Tigres del Norte cuya
historia se puede ver en el documental
Los Tigres del Norte historias que
contar Hoy hace escala en París su
director Carlos Pérez Osorio bienvenido
Muchísimas gracias gracias Y también
tenemos al productor José nací
bienvenido Gracias por estar con
nosotros Muchísimas gracias Bueno Los
Tigres del Norte documental que se
presenta estos días en el festival Viva
México de París y el documental comienza
con este tema El jefe de jefes el correo
es un género musical que narra historias
épicas de México se consolidó en la
Revolución Mexicana temas sobre sus
líderes
contrabandistas familias y si hay un
grupo que representa todo esto es Los
Tigres del Norte quienes reinmentaron el
género una banda familiar Los Hermanos
Hernández y un primo Óscar Lara Cómo
nace este este proyecto José nacid pues
evidentemente después de de de tantos
años de trayectoria el grupo ya tenía la
inquietud de de contar su historia y
nosotros tuvimos el privilegio de
conocerlos ya hacen muchos años y de y
de poder junto con ellos ir articulando
lo que querían hacer y que y como
querían contar su historia algo que pues
evidentemente nos nos representa mucho
en México y pues era hora de contar la
historia de un grupo tan importante en
Carlos Pérez Osorio Cómo fue trabajar
con ellos pasaron muchas horas el
documental bueno la digamos ahí lo
conductor es esa reunión no que hay en
un restaurante Y a partir de la cual se
va hablando de la historia van
desgranando no no toda su trayectoria
como fue trabajar con ellos pues fue
sorprendentemente al principio fácil no
este estar con ellos
se siente muy Familiar no creo que ellos
sean caracterizado por ser unos
profesionales no y Se tomaron con
seriedad del documental pasamos mucho
tiempo con ellos para entender realmente
por dónde encarar la historia no Y
también entender ellos que querían
contar de su historia y de su
trayectoria que es tan larga tan basta y
justamente lo del restaurante Pues fue
un detonante para estas historias para
estas conversaciones que no tenían hace
muchísimo tiempo no es un restaurante en
donde ellos en a principios de los 70s
iban no con quién era su manager Y eso
creo que fue algo que los sentirse muy
cómodos para empezar a contar su
historia como muchas historias en México
la historia de Los Tigres empieza en un
rancho Modesto la noche en el pueblo de
rosa morada Mocorito en Sinaloa en los
años 60 cuando los hermanos Hernández
deciden irse para buscarse la vida
tocando
[Música]
Porque queríamos ser famosos
era para beneficio de nuestra familia tu
papá mamá
siempre decía la escuela primero pero
también tenemos que trabajar
[Música]
no teníamos nombre como grupo musical
pero pero cantamos juntos
mi papá Recibe un balazo a raíz de ese
accidente las cosas toman otro camino
decidimos irnos de ahí del rancho salir
a trabajar teníamos la necesidad de
ayudar a nuestros papás aprendimos el
vuelo hacia Estados Unidos era una
oportunidad única para nosotros no
prácticamente ir restaurante por
restaurant bar por bares podría haber
puesto el acento en muchos aspectos no
viendo la historia de Los Tigres pero en
este documental lo han puesto en la
familia y en la migración porque no sé
quién quiere responder Carlos sí no pues
te digo como enfrentando contar la
historia de Los Tigres
entre más conoces de ellos te das cuenta
pues de todo lo que representan todo lo
que han hecho no no han parado de
trabajar desde los setentas
demasiadas cosas que contar no
demasiados temas y pasando tiempo con
ellos es donde nos dimos cuenta que una
que no se había contado una que la gente
no conocía de estos ídolos de estos
símbolos no de de México era justamente
eso no su vida más personal entender que
que hay personas detrás de la leyenda de
los Tigres del Norte No que se enfrentan
a retos no que que que han hecho
sacrificios y sobre todo también
junto con esto y por esto es que
representan tanto para la gente que
migra no no solamente ya de México sino
de todo el mundo yo creo que actualmente
sí muchas otras personas en el mundo
conocieran la música Los Tigres del
Norte se identificarían no gente mucho
más allá de América Claro porque les
apodan La Voz del pueblo también no
porque ellos mismos tienen una historia
de migración y los mexicanos o incluso
bueno en otros latinoamericanos en
California o en otros estados se
identifican no con con esa historia de
vida es esa tal vez la clave de Los
tigres José sin duda ellos han sido
cronistas de lo que ha pasado en la
frontera o en las fronteras en América y
ellos han sabido contar muy bien la
historia del día a día de lo que
representa el trabajo lo que representa
la migración el mediano y el largo plazo
que la verdad nos parece increíble ahora
bueno tiene una trayectoria
impresionante Pero los primeros años no
fue muy fácil lo vemos en el documental
y hubo una persona que fue crucial en su
carrera que fue Arthur Walker que le
llaman Arturo caminante ellos
y él hizo cambiar ciertas cosas que
hicieron que Los tigres empezarán a
tener éxito que cambió
pues Arthur Walker llegó a la vida de
Los tigres ellos estando muy jóvenes
todavía no recién llegados en el 68 69
yo creo que Arthur representó muchas
cosas para Los tigres no se convirtió en
un mentor una persona en la que ellos
confiaban mucho y también por esto
Después de tres discos grabados Arthur
le sugiere cambiar un poco el estilo de
la música y también es un hombre inglés
que no hablo español que viene a querer
cambiar
cosas en la música norteña que
tradicionalmente pues no no eran así no
y que Los tigres no entendían muy bien
pero confiaban tanto en él que que lo
seguían no y creo que tuvieron una
relación de muchos años este
de familia no casi de que Hernán vivió
un tiempo con Arthur y su esposa o sea
tener relación muy cercana entonces
Los tigres desde muy jóvenes siendo tan
inteligentes no y estratégicos en su
carrera pues decidieron seguirlo y pues
acertaron no cambiaron
la música norteña para siempre y por fin
llegó ese éxito no que se iniciaba con
Contrabando y traición que es más
conocida bueno popularmente como Camelia
la Texana y nací así el mito de Los
Tigres del Norte pero no hay que olvidar
que ellos no componían ellos
interpretaban no detrás de esas
canciones hay hay compositores no en el
documental lo vemos muy bien no
O sea Ellos saben y tienen el termómetro
de qué es lo que quieren de lo que
quieren hablar y y pudieron hacer
grandes equipos con grandes compositores
que inyectaban mucha energía combinado
con lo que Arthur Walker les vino a
implementar en términos del bajo
eléctrico la batería o sea influencias
de rock and roll de de de blues que que
le dieron una identidad muy especial y
muy única en el documental aparece
Julieta Venegas hablando de Los Tigres
del Norte es fan ella de Los tigres o
cómo fue esa colaboración con el
documental sí Julieta trabajó con ellos
también participó en un disco que
hicieron de
covers digamos de Los Tigres del Norte
desde otros géneros musicales Entonces
sí es fan del género Y es de Tijuana
también del Norte Entonces
le emocionó la idea de participar en el
documental hay una relación vital entre
hablábamos antes antes de crónicas no de
la migración con esas canciones
interpretadas por los tigres hay una
relación con la literatura Finalmente y
los corridos no O sea esas Crónicas de
la historia
también entrevistan a Arturo Pérez
reverte no el escritor español que
destaca justamente la importancia que
tienen los tigres para esa memoria
colectiva no sé si si va por ahí también
el documental no por supuesto de hecho
él él cuenta también que a partir de
escuchar los corridos de
tigres él se inspira para escribir La
reina del sur y y ahí es donde le
encuentro todos estos detalles que
inician su investigación para poder
nutrir su su historia y es que sí O sea
tienen más de 500 canciones entre las
que pues sí destacan muchas historias
muy especiales de del tema La reina del
sur de Pérez reverte que es sobre la
narcotraficante Teresa Mendoza
de la que se hizo una película Los
tigres interpretan la canción en este
documental pasan un poco de puntillas
sobre los narcocorridos que son esos
corridos que hablan sobre los
narcotraficantes y que incluso se han
prohibido en algunos estados estaba
viendo un poco en los diarios el tema y
vi que se prohibieron
en 2012 se multó en Chihuahua a los
organizadores de una fiesta Ganadera
porque los tigres interpretaron
narcocorridos Por qué no abordan ese
tema o la abordan así como muy rapidito
en el en el documental es algo querido o
ellos no querían hablar del tema del
narcocorrido porque es un poco polémico
porque las autoridades dicen que esto es
una apología que se elogia a la
violencia y a los narcotraficantes
yo creo particularmente que también es
un tema que no ha sido tan importante en
ese sentido sabes como que en la
prohibición y todo si tú te pones a ver
en estos 50 años de carrera son muy
contaditos los casos en los que ha
pasado esto y el y ha sido muy
muy poco la repercusión que ha tenido
esta prohibición No creo que es más como
una una fama no un tema que se que se
expande mucho porque genera morbo no
revisando como toda la carrera de Los
tigres y te digo no es un tema que
estaba considerado por supuesto en el
documental pero se tuvieron que tomar
decisiones no sobre De qué se iba a
tratar este documental creo que ese tema
en particular no era el que más nos
interesaba no para para este documental
en particular
y Tratamos de meterlo de alguna manera
un poco no con la polémica de jefe de
jefes no sobre quién está escrito
entonces preguntamos no a la gente que
que es que bueno el compositor no a
Teodoro bello a los mismos tigres a la
gente que pensaba no de de para quién
estaba escrito y bueno cada quien dio su
punto de vista no pero nos pareció que
centrarnos más en la familia y en la
migración pues era mucho más interesante
no que Seguir generando narrativa sobre
narcotráfico en México Bueno pues
muchísimas gracias ya no nos queda más
tiempo Carlos Pérez Osorio y José
nacibles deseamos muchísimo éxito Con
con este documental sobre los Tigres del
Norte historias que contar y vamos a
terminar como lo hacen en el en el
documental con el tema Somos más
americanos en Los Tigres del Norte con
Zacarías Manuel de la rocha que es el
cantante de
Muchísimas gracias Y muchísimas gracias
a todos ustedes por habernos acompañado
ya saben que también nos pueden seguir
por internet en rf y mundo.com y
france24.com hasta pronto amigos
[Aplausos]
[Música]